this is pretty cool we are at a
restaurant called juice aku and we are
about to enjoy a ceremonial meal called
a chi Seki pi ii chi sake
yeah isn't it what I said if it is I
reinforced what you said okay
you look well lovely thank you the high
priest of meaningless conversation ayato
I understand that you just learned the
word arigato
but it is not applicable for every
situation it is to say thank you and I
was thanking her for coming into the
room right so what's wrong with that
what context
it was never wrong Ambala Iowa Iowa is a
state that is not relevant here Ohio is
what I wanted to say uh-huh what's Ohio
that would be hello in the morning I
said Iowa as I thought that was me
saying hello right and that was not me
trying to made a mistake you were
incorrect well I do applaud the effort
she is moments away from drowning
herself in the koi pond rather than here
one second more of this babbling ooh
what is that just sit you work for me we
don't have to constantly speak this from
you
the man who turns the slightest answer
to a question into a Russian novel sorry
for my friend Yeah right
international language are you doing
mmm-hmm you're a pervert when you're
smelling a lady's shoe let's just
remember that every aspect of Japanese
culture is influenced in some part by
the Shinto beliefs that the gods the
comi are everywhere they're in every
object and they flow through us the
Shinto is everywhere in us as well I
think you're full of Sh in tow if you
pass me your glass I will honor you by
filling your sock a glass
oh you fill mine you can choose and then
I can whether you want to do the same
return the honor for me and know
[Applause]
ah that is good soup a probiotic soup
like miso will fortify your intestinal
flora improve both your digestion but
also your overall health and immunity
really yeah that's funny cuz I find you
hard to stomach don't wanna go mr.
Roboto now some of these dishes were yes
you were right to laugh I'm very funny
I gotta go yes genius she knows what you
want to see and she gives it to she's
laughing for real no she ought to tell
that I'm being funny she's not humoring
me there is nothing laughing is imagine
you and I don't think you're funny right
I doubt that's it thanks for coming what
is funny about you and I'm sure this
nice waitress well maybe you should may
not understand what we say assumes that
I'm the one in power why do you think
she's because I understand this culture
and we resonate like a windowpane upon
hearing a certain frequency vibrating
back and forth
she and I are resonated you think you're
resonating with her yes I'm the one that
makes her laugh everywhere the fly
banging against the window she likes you
because you're a jester I'm the one she
will eventually marry chocolate could
you pour me some more yes I honor you
and you can choose whether you want to
do the same please for me and no my
question for you is Jordan yeah in
addition to Italy you've had a long
obsession with Japan when did that begin
for you my fascination with Japanese
culture began with the Karate Kid Part
two now that movie was shot and took
place in Okinawa southern part of Japan
and well Daniel was staying at a ryokan
which is a oh oh yeah Daniel sung played
by Ralph hamachi which is actually the
Italian Way pronounced Macchio but I
believe he pronounces it Macchio and
I'll respect his decision
so Jordan looks recap yeah your entire
fascination
with Japan mm-hmm stems from the fact
that you saw Karate Kid - yeah and that
it was filmed in where Okinawa Okinawa I
have a message here for you please press
play and hold that out to the camera as
you watch it
hi Conan it's me Ralph Macchio listen
I'm sorry to interrupt I just wanted to
tell that Jordan guy that all the scenes
in Karate Kid Part two that was supposed
to be Japan were actually shot in Hawaii
[Applause]
it was no thank you
Ralph Macchio you fraud I understand you
make fraud I think right now you're in
shock yes
and you're gonna try and talk yourself
out of it no no I'm your childhood hero
just came out of my phone yeah it took a
[ __ ] into your mouth
I am shocked that you had our talent
Booker reach out to his publicist you
have the connections yeah I can get to
Ralph Macchio yeah yes you can you sir
our fool I've you server Ralph Macchio
shot running into you because I'm
watching a movie which son it's Macchio
machi to him if I wanted to
it's John Smith oh yeah yeah I can get
some Akio listen to you right now you
sound like an insane stalker we have
footage of you with your eyes as wide as
an owl sing
[Applause]
you
you